I ain't I the luckiest guy in the world
I just found the perfect little helper
what is it with you guys in my family
helping the cops do their job is not
some some privilege it's a trap I'm not
your informant your partner or your
friend the people of Salem are a strange
Bunch
with a serial murderer on the loose the
slow minded citizenry seek safety in a
creepy playground at night and often
alone or maybe they take a cue from the
intrepid individuals currently on a
graveyard tour once again in the dead of
night clearly they do not understand
fear or how sane people would react
during periods of stress murdered soul
suspect is full of these abnormalities
it struggles to frame the supernatural
events in a way that is easily relatable
it's easy to laugh at sole suspect so
why is it so engrossing sole suspects
focus on dissecting people's minds
overshadows its many many missteps
learning the sad details of a girl
murdered by a hooded assailant may be
incredibly uncomfortable
what could possibly compel someone to
commit such a heinous deed the same
sense of unease manifested when I
encountered a ghost who did not realize
that he was dead it assumed his
girlfriend would still come back to him
I cared about the people in Salem even
though so few of them are flushed outs
are more than just caricatures I wanted
to learn their fate are we in for
it's too complicated to get into let's
just say that I wasn't about to let some
judge decide how to spend the rest of my
life that's my choice so I made it
either way no it doesn't matter now does
it
things don't start out too strong Liam
sole suspect you plays ronin a former
criminal who atone for his youthful
errors by joining the police force then
he gets killed by a hooded man and
becomes a ghost hoping to solve the
mystery of his own death he's tough in a
generic distance way that's immediately
off-putting
there's a little more to his personality
than the stoic puffing of a ghostly
cigarettes in the occasional longing for
his deceased ex
Ronin doesn't become more developed even
as you learn more pieces of his life
he's a doll a Parisian who lets his many
tattoos tell a story for him I honestly
didn't even care who finished him off at
any point in the game which seems like a
pretty big problems considering the
entire game is built around solving that
mystery but it's his voyeuristic
tendencies that I found so interesting
as a ghost there's little you can do
aside from snooping on the living you
walk through walls without a care in the
world and survey rooms to find clues
leading you to nebulous answers maybe
you're trying to figure out what caused
a drowned woman to perish while the
other people in the boat were saved or
you're putting together the pieces of a
terrible situation in a police station
there are many ghosts who need your help
in seeing their final moments replayed
kept me pushing forward the most
intriguing of these story threads
belongs to your ex her life was shrouded
in mystery and contradictions that she
was constantly reconciling why does she
trust a former criminal how could
someone with such an open heart have
committed so many felonies and what role
did her own mental instability playing
her decisions gathering these pieces
flushed out her character in ways Ronin
never reaches and provided a stabilizing
presence as I pressed onward the many
faults that surface serve as humorous
diversions rather than sources of
frustration the forced combat sections
that are complete
unnecessary as you vanquish roving
demons the head-scratching stealth
mission that doesn't make any sense
because the medium you're traveling with
was given permission to roam the guarded
premises the goofy cats you inhabit who
you can make me out constantly while
their silly little mouths move
these situations provide levity in a
game that clashes with the serious tone
and even the active exploration is
riddled with problems most of the game
is just walking around discovering clues
to the various stories that exist in
Salem there are so many glitches that
even something as simple as this has
problems for instance items you've
already interacted with remain glowing
they think it seem like there's still
more for you to do or they shimmer as if
they don't exist making you wonder if
it's a bug or just the ethereal plane
messing with you I kept searching
because I loved discovering all these
tidbits even when these problems
surfaced but it still felt shoping
uneven murdered soul suspect is a
strange strange game it does everything
in its power to push you away that is
the taciturn protagonist tired visual
design improper music and brainless
citizens it's empowering to gather the
pieces to the many stories letting you
see the lives of the people play out in
sad detail at least sole suspect has
more spirit than Ronan could ever muster
wrong even when aim is right